[Música]
hola a todos bueno yo soy doménica y hoy
vamos a traer nuestra primera clase de
actuación
hoy vamos a hablar acerca de la
construcción de un personaje
y lo que natura no da stanislavski no
otorga este señor fue actor fue director
de teatro y fue creador de un método
importantísimo para muchísimos actores
alrededor del mundo que se llamó el
método de interpretación están en las
que este método contaba con ciertos
parámetros para que una persona un actor
pueda crear un personaje bueno yo les
quiero contar que a mí me hubiese
encantado interpretar un personaje pero
antes quiero explicarles lo que es un
personaje un personaje es un ser que
puede ser real o ficticio que está
dentro de una obra que puede ser
literaria cinematográfico teatral es
decir es una persona que tiene una vida
a mí me hubiese encantado
que estas funciones
pero no funciona todavía
ok a mí me hubiese encantado interpretar
a china porque porque claro china era
una mujer fuerte una mujer valiente una
mujer que no necesitaba ser protegida
contigo le veía a través de la pantalla
yo sentía que esta mujer era capaz de
hacerlo absolutamente todo además yo
sentía que china era doblemente
interesante porque además de ser una
temeraria guerrera también era una
hermosa hermosísima princesa que podía
soltar su armadura soltarse el cabello
peinarlo
podía
dar su página burbujas quisiera podía
reclamar un espacio para ella mismo
donde ella podría ser y sentirse
vulnerable dócil ser honesta
incluso podía hasta llorar por algún
desengaño amoroso que como todos ya
sabemos los hombres son terriblemente
mentirosos y no quiero hablar acerca de
los hombres costeños porque esos son los
peores
pero por más glamourosa que me pareciera
china por más esplendorosa y perfecta
para interpretar yo no pude interpretar
a china no pude hacerlo no tuve el
coraje de hacerlo y mi construcción de
personaje tomó otro rumbo no fue china
si no fue daniel
sí
bueno dentro de las características más
notables de daniel era que era una
persona muy condescendiente y muy
complaciente en él aprendió muy rápido
lo que exactamente tenía que decir pero
sobre todo lo que no tenía que decir
danielle no podía hablar de sus sueños
de sus gustos de sus deseos no podía
hablar de amor no podía hablar de
sexualidad era un niño muy reprimido no
era no era aburrido no era no
interesante de hecho no personas
interesante era creativo era positivo
era empático era fácil de llevar lo que
bueno claramente después de un tiempo
continua me convertí en esta mujer que
soy ahora ya se torna un poco difícil y
si no me querían preguntar a la gente
que organizó ted que se mataba en la
cabeza trató de organizar algo conmigo
porque soy un poco aplicada pero daniel
tenía un gran gran problema daniel no
decía todo lo que quería callaba mucho
más de lo que él podía decir entonces
ustedes se preguntarán
porque escoger a daniel y no escoger a
china que me parecía tan maravillosa
bueno interpretar a daniel era mucho más
fácil y era un asunto de supervivencia
para mí también porque
ser daniel representaba en el poco
porcentaje posible en lo que un niño en
lo que un varón o un hombre podía
representar como lo aceptable lo normal
les cuento que a duras penas y con
suerte daniel pasaba así de agache en
frente a la gente como un niño
tranquilito como un niño educado como
muy niño hasta de niño adicto pero la
realidad era que danielle que hallaban
muchísimas muchísimas cosas
entonces en esta construcción mía de
este personaje me di cuenta de que
daniel también era valiente y también
estaba dispuesto a hacer muchísimas
cosas que yo como persona no estaba
dispuesta a hacer les digo que era un
asunto de supervivencia también porque
siempre siempre es mucho más fácil y más
cómodo tratar de acoplarse al molde que
tratar de romperlo y para mí ser daniel
era la única posibilidad que yo tenía de
sentirme dentro de sentirme parte de
algo de sentirme incluida en algo no
danielle sigue siendo hoy un personaje
muy importante en mi vida yo nunca voy a
dejar de ser daniel es parte de mi
esencia es parte de lo que soy de lo que
fui también
pero algo más importante
son los estudios realizados por
muchísimas personas que son muy muy
pocos ahora les voy a presentar uno pero
les voy a decir también que hay
muchísima gente que trata de estudiar
acerca de temas trans y sobre todo
acerca de temas trans en la niñez y no
tenemos ningún tipo de estudio que los
rebeles porque las personas transgéneros
nos enfrentamos a muchísimos obstáculos
por ejemplo la reducción de presupuesto
muy poca difusión muy poco apoyo muy
poco interés por la sociedad de la
comunidad científica para investigar
cosas importantes como los niños trans y
viste una noticia que es terrible y
espero que les parezca terrible también
yo aunque no hubiera tenido la vocación
de actriz aún así aún así hubiese tenido
que interpretar el papel de daniel
y así hay muchísimos niños en el mundo
que tienen que interpretar a su propio
en el que tienen que levantarse todos
los días tratando de ponerse una máscara
para ser aceptados y para sentirse parte
de una sociedad que si no siente que
está que si no siente la sociedad que
está encaminado entonces lo rechaza
dentro de las oportunidades que tuvo de
investigar temas temas trans en algún
momento investigue sobre sobre las
personas trans que pudieron haber sido
victimarios y adivinen cuántas cuántos
estudios te encontré
pero estudios lo que encontré un montón
de estudios en donde los países estaban
de acuerdo o no a permitir a las
personas trans a por ejemplo acceder a
el cambio de género o de nombre en la
cédula si tú no tienes
un avistamiento una visibilidad para el
estado no existe es simplemente no
existe no puedes reclamar nada ni puedes
disfrutar nada aquí les voy a mostrar
una imagen en donde hay algunos países
en los que se puede hacer y en los que
no se puede ser claramente vemos que
américa está con un 12%
quiero retomar lo de la actuación porque
importante hay muchísima gente alrededor
del mundo tratando interpretar un
personaje y el mensaje que les traigo
este día es que aprendamos a conocer a
las personas y entendamos que todo el
mundo distinto porque no es tan
diferente tampoco aprendamos a amarnos
dejémonos amar estudiamos lo queremos
estudiar hablemos de lo que queremos
hablar vencemos a qué queremos besar
amemos a qué queremos amar pero sin
máscaras sin personajes sin danieles yo
tuve la decisión y tuve la gracia de
tener la decisión de ser actriz pero
muchísima gente transgénero que no tiene
esa oportunidad y yo hoy puedo
interpretar àngel puede interpretar a
china si quiero hoy interpretar a
cualquier personaje que me proponga pero
hay muchísima gente transgénero que
tiene que vivir toda la vida
interpretando un personaje hay una
paradoja interesante cuando yo ya estuve
frente a la escena después de haberme
preparado casi que toda mi infancia para
este personaje me di cuenta de que
debajo de los reflectores
esa máscara que tenía yo de daniel me
pesaba demasiado y entonces aprecio esta
persona que ven ustedes y que tienen
ustedes enfrente que es doménica y así
como yo hay muchísima gente aquí en este
salón que está todavía intentando
descubrir quién es yo sé quién soy
todavía no sé dónde voy pero lo más
importante es que te acepte como eres y
eso es lo que le quería compartir a todo
esto este en este día muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]